[Music]  parliament is celebrating gender  equality week  25 years after the beijing declaration  the most ambitious road map  ever for advancing women's rights since  its adoption  parliament has taken steps to end  violence against women and girls  it has adopted anti-harassment measures  and passed the anti-trafficking  directive  meps are calling to mainstream gender  into all eu policies  the 21st century is the century of women  we are facing the  year 2050 and not the image of women  in the 1950s so we are looking forward  and not back  parliament is renewing its call for  rules obliging companies to have 40  women on their boards it supports equal  pay and representation at work and in  public life  and has taken steps to protect work-life  balance  meps will continue to fight for gender  equality across our society  you